hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jessie I'm Jessie and today we're
not gonna do what I said we were gonna
do yesterday which was try out a new
JavaScript CMS and I'll explain why in a
minute but what we are going to do is
pull out some more data from our sequel
server database and we're going to use
our our nodejs code that we that the
Harshit wrote and we're gonna put it
into my sequel database using the
wordpress api we'll need to make some
custom post types so we'll be working
with a wordpress plugin we'll bring over
that one that we have used on some some
other projects that we made and we'll
modify that to fit our our first custom
post type we'll make will be faculty so
that's what we'll work on the only other
thing that I think we'll need to do is
we'll have to do something about the way
the HTML is getting pulled in to
WordPress so I'm looking up some things
on Stack Overflow that you all had had
mentioned last week at some point so
we'll try to get that working but we
should be able to get a decent amount of
work done today I don't have any
meetings so we can have a kind of a
normal length stream here so for sure I
want to try to get into Pomodoro
sessions of work with questions in
between and after and depending on how
it's going maybe we'll go longer we'll
see and oh my headphones my music go on
let's get that going first
hey everyone seen the live chat Blake's
mentioning right so I did just get a
haircut
so anyway
yes I feel nice and fresh my haircut if
does anyone use Spotify that's watching
so I guess Spotify just came out with
well within the last week sometime the
your top songs of 2017 playlist so I
don't know it's pretty fun I definitely
wouldn't want to share it with everybody
because I'd be embarrassed I'm somewhat
embarrassed by some of the songs that it
says that I listen to the most but but
it is fun going back through and
projects I was working on when I was
listening to certain songs all the time
so that's really fun
just to remember like oh yeah I listen
to that all the time when I was working
on you know this website so did bring
back memories anyway so if you haven't
looked that up yet check out see if you
can find your top songs playlist on your
Spotify account it's a lot of fun all
right let's Gordon asks what CMS are you
porting from the CMS is called Ektron
and I'm not a big fan of it I haven't
had a lot of good experiences using
Ektron and it's old and the company that
made it got bought up by another company
so I don't really think it has much of a
future so we need to be done with it so
let me I don't really need this right
now I don't need that let's see where
we're going I was working on this
earlier but I don't think I need it you
know we don't need that
I shouldn't have anything unsafe so I'm
gonna not say that we don't need any of
this none of that none of that we need
that sorry I just I was not prepared at
all I ran into one of my former students
from when I used to teach high school
I was getting a haircut and I talked to
her for a while afterwards so it set me
back a little bit I didn't get as much
time to prepare as I normally do I see
um you got a question from alright I
know how I supposed to pronounce this on
um Hill is that how I pronounce it yo
let me know I'm trying to pronounce it
I'm sure I remember anyway I asked
what's up with the branch on Gatsby the
restaurant Gatsby I haven't worked on
but it's I'm leaving it open and I want
to try to work on it I really wanted to
try to work on them both a little bit
the next branch in the Gatsby branch and
then test them out and see which one was
faster I still would like to do that but
realistically I've got to be conscious
of the amount of time we have to
complete this project there's still a
lot of work to be done
and it needs to be done by February so
if if we have to I don't know wait and
finish that branch like afterwards then
that can be pushed so basically it's
something that's not necessary for us to
do this project can certainly work and
we know it can work with next so I think
our best bet is to if we need to for
time just work on the branch that is
using next and work on the Gatsby branch
later some other time for testing
purposes okay
Blake's asking about question on the FCC
slack Channel I don't have a slack
channel open right now maybe I can I can
take a look at it later on the all right
so we won't need a login to this tell me
this faster USA's
why's it not there we go alright okay
great
so we brought these posts in last time
and as you can see they came in like
actually did it come in right this time
that's interesting
whoa all right I don't know if any of
y'all just caught that so we were having
a problem before where we brought all
this data in and these tags weren't
there so you could see like route list
view image detail view image like you
know all these custom tags weren't there
and we were getting a different view so
what I just did was if I go to visual
and then I go back then you can see all
those tags are gone it's they're all
switched around but if I just go back
out to posts and I come back in here you
can see the tags are there again so I
think we're okay with that the I'm
assuming what would happen is if I
switch to visual edited something and
then updated it that we would lose these
tags so at least this is good news
because at first we can still import
data without having to fix that problem
of the the tags getting getting changed
but whenever I open this up and let
other people come in and start editing I
would have to i'd have to fix that issue
so that's actually good because now we
don't have to deal with that on today's
stream which I thought I wanted to to
fix that before I even started streaming
today but I just ran out of time okay
cool so at this point then let's let's
build a plug-in to make some custom post
types and then we'll install that
plug-in here on our test WordPress
install and then we'll pull pull over
some data
yeah okay let's do that so the first
thing we'll need to do is grab the
plug-in from a previous project try to
think if I have that plug-in available
on github I don't think I do I could
probably just grab it from WordPress
install we've already worked with
catechetical Institute yeah so I'm gonna
grab it from a
katak addicts car
okay let's fine yep this is it this is
our project
if you see my head bobbing a little bit
don't laugh at me I'm listening to some
some music that has a really good beat
so I just can't help it alright so let
me throw this plug in here and let's
change this to PHP so we can get that
syntax highlighting wonderful and I
definitely need to make this bigger so
everyone can see I don't need this right
now
and oops let me start my timer let me
start this Pomodoro timer
harsh is saying try custom posts UI is
that a plug-in is that a different
plug-in I was kind of thinking I just
use our current plug-in that we've
already built
okay
all right so we can just grab basically
we can just change change these for now
just to faculty
would I do that
and actually we don't the plural of
faculty is faculty maybe kids a faculty
member
okay so that's what we need for now
and then we can get rid of all the rest
of this
oops I need to keep that it's at the
bottom
and why did it do that resource that's
weird
okay so it's going to support obviously
a title editor should we have an excerpt
yeah I'm gonna have the expert excerpt
in there just in case definitely one of
them now okay that looks good
post slug faculty we definitely want to
show in the API showing menu okay that
looks good down here with our taxonomy
x'
do we need this Google map API
no I don't think we'll need this so
let's get rid of this Google map yeah we
use this on on that catechetical
Institute project ok change title of
your title Fatima murders
all right are we gonna need to do this
all right I'm gonna comment this out for
now because we might need it but just
not right now so let me explain what
this codes don't we know that I've kind
of cut out the stuff that we don't need
and I'm gonna comment this for now as
well oops yeah I don't think I'm gonna
do custom taxonomy right now we'll see
all right let me explain a little bit
and then I'll decide about that so
here's what we're doing here we've
created a plugin a wordpress plugin so
we've just given it a name and
description you know just some basic
stuff here at the top and within this
function create new type right we're
creating new post types so we've created
a post type with the name of faculty
right and then we've just given it some
some options here so a singular name
this is the name of for the the add new
button so it'll say add new faculty the
edit so basically we were just given the
names that all these labels on the post
will have right and down here we're
registering this type and we're giving
it you know some options so we want it
to have a title that can be edited in an
editor excerpt thumbnail we want it to
be shown in the rest API we wanted to
show in the menu in the admin panel
we've given it a slug of faculty right
so it's pretty straightforward you know
how this works
you definitely need to know what the
right you know words are to use and then
down here you know we're just creating
that types or so that's it I mean that's
the main point down here though you can
create custom taxonomies and we may want
to do this but first I just wanted to
make sure that this works and we've done
it right and then we'll
- we'll get to these so I'm gonna just
comment these out for now and then we
may come back it might not be a bad idea
to make a custom type for the faculty
members that says their department oops
alright so I'm just gonna copy all of
this and it's the new again actually
maybe I need to just see if I'm gonna
add a new plugin like this yeah I need
to upload it first before I can I don't
think I can and you appear you making
the record is you plug yeah yeah let me
make let's save this first
yeah we may as well say that as far to
this project
so the custom post type stuff PHP and
then let's go in here
all right so we made a zip file for this
which is what WordPress wants let's go
back to our plugins directory upload
this plugin
No 68
oh man this this little ending piece
right there all right let's go can we
edit this editor
all right let's see if this works not
in 57 I think I commented something out
that I should not have shows one wears
on
I think that was it
no I let's see
yes
oh no this is a problem okay now I do
need that to be closed somewhere I don't
think I ever closed it that's close yeah
that should be closed
hmm
I'm gonna check my other version of this
plug-in yeah I did miss one here okay
oops
all right
let's edit this one more time this
should work
yeah okay it worked all right so now we
have this post type called faculty we
can go in and add new faculty right and
the info should come in here so this is
where where we had imported these posts
before that we're faculty members now
we're gonna put it in here so this is
all we need for now we're not going to
do any custom post types yet just to try
to get all this data in here and quickly
enough to get the site finished on time
if we have time or potentially even
after the site launches we can go back
in and make some custom post types it'll
clean things up a bit make it a lot
easier to edit later on but for now
we're just going to dump everything into
this you know kind of WYSIWYG editor all
right now let me now let me go through
we do need
hmm we may be able to just put a
category in here if I make it so that
this supports categories I don't make a
custom taxonomy
all right let's let's see
and
category select how do you spell
category we're just wrong with me
yeah that's it category there we go
all right that should do it the process
for updating the plugins is not
spectacular I'm sure there's a better
way to set it up but for right now I'm
not I shouldn't need to edit this that
watch hmm okay
plugins editor
all right let's see if we can now put
categories in em
we cannot
hmm
maybe I need to oops
so it is in there so maybe there's a
look up how to do that then or make a
custom taxonomy alright so we also have
our our code that we used to migrate
things over so we're gonna use this
again we're gonna do it just like we did
before
yeah just like we did before those data
but we are gonna need to change some of
this so that we're not we don't want
this to go to posts we now want it to go
to faculty
let's see
oh you know what I think the the URL was
in our config which let me switch off
here for a minute so I can't show
everyone that can fake is in you'll see
all the passwords and stuff so let's
let's change this up a bit
yeah we change this up okay so in our
config we were bringing like the full
URL now I do not want to do that anymore
we're gonna bring
all right
okay so let me switch back alright so
here's what I've changed before
everything was contained in this WP URI
meaning it had the word posts in there
so that everything that we were putting
through here to be sent to WordPress was
was called was being added in as a post
we don't want it to be though what we
want to see is we want out of the option
to make things you know basically
whatever whatever we want it to be in
this case faculty so let's give it I
guess we can give it a shot at this
point let's see how much time we have
six minutes okay and I know I haven't
checked the live chat in a bit I will as
soon as this timer runs out whether we
get just running it through to make sure
we have everything we need
all right we were trying to make the
category faculty did we accomplish that
last time or not I want to double-check
see if these posts actually had a
category I think we did not I think they
ended up not having a category yeah so
they came through son categorized
now before we bring it in we really
should get this put in here as faculty
because no not as faculty we want the
type of faculty does if we pull too much
data in then we'll have to go in and
manually add that and I don't I don't
really want to do that that's gonna take
too much time if we figure out how to do
this right now then it'll save a lot of
time in the long run so let's let's
check out what we would have
hmm actually I can't check that out now
we have no content in the Faculty let's
see yes let's put in a text on to me
should I do it like this
anything
yeah I think this is a good way to do it
all right so we're gonna make a new
taxonomy for the faculty and so you
don't want to be neighbor resource
categories
okay so we've given these are all the
labels that are going to appear in the
admin section of WordPress and then here
we've we've just added some options
giving it a slug we wanted to show up an
admin menu we want it to show up in in a
REST API so let's save that copy it over
into WordPress plugins
okay
and see if it works
maybe it's not working because the
plug-in is still running no strong thing
let's deactivate that for a second okay
less than a minute now I'll go back to
the live chat check out what's going on
there
alright let's go back in here activate
it see if it's done anything
mm-hmm and it is not worked okay I'm
pretty sure I know what I did wrong but
my time is up
see
there we go okay so see now we have
faculty Department so philosophy so we
have the faculty department philosophy
now so this will work just like
categories work on a regular wordpress
post but we've now made it custom so
alright so that's how you do it and this
we have enabled the hierarchy which is
kind of nice we may or may not use this
but in case we need to at some point we
have it okay great now let's take a
five-minute break and I'm gonna go back
to the live chat looks like there's a
lot going on in here so let me scroll up
and get through as much as I can
okay horseshit I see you you posted
stuff about the custom post type UI
thing I will check it out yeah I'll
check that out I found I've looked at
this one before and to be honest so
here's here's the reason why I didn't
want to go with a plug-in before one
when I can just like copy and paste and
do this like quickly it ends up being
faster I know it didn't seem that fast
before because I had a missing bracket
and and I missed that but now I've
gotten through that those are mistakes
that I'm not likely to repeat in the
near future so it's actually faster for
me to just copy and paste these whereas
if I went with a visual editor I would
have to fill out all the fields every
time so I don't like that also my
philosophy when it comes to WordPress
plugins or if I can do something
efficiently myself then it guarantees
that I know for sure what's in that
plug-in and it's as lean as possible so
you know plug-in this post I plug-in
which I'm sure is is very nice and
effective it does come with a lot of
extra stuff like you know all the stuff
that determines what the UI is right and
where we were we have no UI involved
here no admin UI so anyway if doing it
this way ends up taking way too long
I'll check out that that other plug-in
and we are actually going to use a
plug-in when we try to make custom
fields because the plug-in does save a
lot of time but custom post types and
taxonomies aren't really that hard to do
you know we have the boilerplate right
here and we just change the names and
that's pretty much it okay
shake thanks explanation
okay looks like there is some confusion
about what I was writing so this is PHP
and that's so WordPress is written
mostly PHP so I was making a wordpress
plugin that has a category that we can
pull our data into so we're not really
going to do anything with PHP for the
rest of the rest of the stream this is
node so we're going to be mainly working
with node and with sequel queries for
the rest of the stream and I probably
won't really show making any more custom
post types on a stream since I've
already demonstrated it once and I know
we've done in previous streams then I
think it'll be fine just to for me to do
that stuff you know else will need
different times during the day
dr. dan says the coat looks really
difficult yeah honestly if I had to
write stuff like that from scratch you
know I assume you talked about the PHP
then it would be difficult but I mean
really when I first made this plugin all
I did was copy what how this was already
being done elsewhere I don't remember
where I first got this from maybe from
the docs I don't know and then just fill
it in what I needed right so it's not
it's not that difficult as long as you
you know that's why I kind of left this
stuff commented out so we have an
example that I I don't touch that's not
messed up of something that works if you
were talking about this node stuff this
is somewhat difficult a little bit more
advanced hard should actually made this
so it wasn't me
I just modify it you know slightly okay
hard should I see you were saying that I
might need to use plural and our here
instead of category I could use
categories yeah that might have worked I
guess it doesn't matter now since we
already added that custom the custom I
think is the nicer way to go because
then it's it's more obvious what is
wanted when it's called departments
instead of categories so it was probably
better that I went that way anyway I was
just trying to do categories so that it
would be a little bit faster
dr. Danis do we have to use sequel
prepared statements with nodejs is it
even possible yeah so let's see oops
wrong file yeah so we're using sequel
eyes which lets us put in just basic
sequel queries and it basically so that
we can use sequel queries in node right
and these are
if the syntax looks weird to you we had
some issues with the syntax so there are
some differences with the syntax between
sequel server from Microsoft and my
sequel so if if some of these look
different it's probably due to that just
a difference in syntax all right didn't
my timer rang but I'm almost to the
bottom here the live chat so let me see
if I can just get through this last few
things here before we move on let's see
Street Fighter motorcycle says 37
watching that only 9 likes unacceptable
audience members yeah I don't I don't
think I can even I can't see the likes
from the admin panel for the the control
room for the live streaming so anyway
I'm not really sure if what the likes do
do they likes play a role and I don't
know how you appear like in searches or
something I I'm not exactly sure I mean
it's nice when people like the videos I
feel good when it happens but I'm not
sure what role they play in in the
overall ranking of videos Oh 13 likes
now nice thanks for all the likes dr.
dan asks if anyone it was from America
here I know we have a lot of people from
America that watch in the stream I am
from America to people in California
Colorado Georgia Texas awesome
haha alright I gotta read this so this
would be probably the last thing that I
read out before we start again with the
code
Brooke said thought taxonomy was
something with dead animals
jonbi says that's taxidermy so that was
pretty funny right I suspect that Brooke
may have known all along it was still
pretty funny alright someone from Peru
welcome Wow up to 21 likes now awesome
so I'm from Poland welcome and Portugal
alright we have people from all over it
I love that
okay so let's set our timer again do
another Pomodoro session and this time
we're gonna try to bring put our data
into the correct post type which is
faculty and we're gonna try to add this
category not a faculty but in this case
these are philosophy faculty so we're
gonna try to add the word philosophy in
here
so here's what's
hmm we're gonna need to see
I'm gonna need to see how this how this
comes in so here actually here's the
problem I think
alright let's let me let's do this
what's the camera with the URL is the PJ
songs me to set it no rest for a post is
it post no was it called
WP j o WP I forgot trying to figure out
what the rest route is there we go
nothing seriously oops
added extra slash okay um
[Music]
okay here's the the issue with
categories so when you get data from the
REST API in the terms of the categories
it's an array but it's an array of the
category IDs so I'm wondering if we need
to create our custom types first get the
ID and then send the ID there
Harshit sang and the live chat check out
the API Doc's for custom post yes so
let's check that those types
okay I really want to see
all right so this is that test post that
I just made and I want to see okay
so faculty Department is here and the
category philosophy is three all right
so let's just grab this this whole thing
and put that in here
okay so okay Australia
let's let's save that and
[Music]
I think that's it and that's all we'll
need all right so now this let's run
this I still don't know what the
shortcut is for the console or the
integrated terminal all right so let's
try melissa's migrate yeah
someone ha ha which I don't like but
that's not the end of the world if
that's the only thing that's that's
being changed people's very break there
may be other things changing it's hard
to read it like this there's a lot of
breaks and in the middle let's see if we
have those you know we don't okay so it
is actually adding in a lot of other
stuff so we're gonna have to fix that I
suppose or at least see how bad it looks
if it still looks okay even with these
additions then I guess it's fine for now
wonderful all right that's great all
right let me let me just go back to the
live chat briefly to see if I messed
anything up that I didn't notice before
we try to do more of this
oh no is this is a stream okay now it
just occurred to me that maybe it wasn't
a good idea to change my network in the
middle of a stream so hopefully it's
alright uh is oh goodness
my not of viewers did drop off let me
know if you can see the stream the
status is saying good in my control
panel but I'm not seeing any activity in
the chat so please let me know alright
it's okay now great thank you
I've been streaming for like seven
months and I can't believe it like it
never occurred to me like hey don't
disconnect yourself from the internet
while you're streaming anyway I had to
change networks because I couldn't
access the database otherwise but anyway
alright it's fine now sorry about that
okay Harshit saying we should use graph
QL R that's that's fine with me I'm
I mean since this works
I'm not going to try to switch it up to
graph QL now but like some point soon if
if you think it'll be faster and easier
to use graph QL to upload this data
instead of just a regular REST API then
I'm I'm all up for doing that but let me
know they said we've been streaming for
about an hour now so I'm not gonna
attempt to implement that right now but
I'm definitely open to it
code CVS what's delay on the stream can
you read out the time when you read this
[Music]
59 to 59 p.m. Eastern Time when I'm
reading this there's that there's a
slight delay I don't know how long the
delay is exactly
alright let's try to bring in let's try
to find and then bring in another
department of faculty members so the
first thing we need to do is bring over
our bars what was this called I always
forget what this is called sequel
operations studio from Microsoft so this
is an electron app from Microsoft that
is sequel operations studio and I think
it's pretty cool I like it it looks a
lot like Visual Studio code first things
first we need to connect what's nice it
automatically connected me that's pretty
awesome alright and we need to take
let's I need a query out of a query the
connection you serve content
and now I had saved queries what did I
say that too
[Music]
here we go
let's try to open that saved query the
area awesome alright let's run that just
to make sure it's working you know
[Music]
connect alright cool
so that is working so let's open up
another query then and we can just come
back in and change the folder ID and
then this should give us what we need so
what was our select star from contents
come on what all right this is gonna
take a little bit because I'm accessing
everything all right cool so I need to
look for something that's obviously
let's see a faculty member
I'm have to figure out a way to narrow
this down a little bit more this is a
lot of data now let me just scroll down
area anderson monica full-ride d 146 all
right let's check 146 let's run that all
right cool so I think this is fine arts
department
why does Nick will have to I don't know
let's see which one is the right one all
right this one looks like there's
nothing in it I'm not gonna try to pull
this out right now we'll just delete it
since it's only one we'll just delete it
from WordPress but these are fine arts
department Oh interesting that this
shows up in here as well we'll delete
that too we definitely don't need that
interesting okay
all right 146 is what we're bringing in
we're there we go so now all we have to
do is we'll switch it to 146 and then
let's make this wall in WordPress let's
make a new new faculty departments let's
go in here we could add them directly so
let's name this Fine Arts
should automatically give us a slug yet
Fine Arts and where's our it's not
saying the ID Annie PID whoa and it's
yeah let's see if I can make it share
the ID no okay let's continue Department
let's see if I can get it here
there we go so I guess I'll have to just
check in the rest API when I add one
which is okay so it's going to be ID
four so let's go in here now and change
it to ID 4 so when I run when I run this
again
after making these changes it should
pull in all of our fine arts faculty
members into our faculty custom post
type with the faculty Department of Fine
Arts so let's try it out
and there we go so now we have fine arts
faculty as well
and let's get rid of this duplicate
which should have nothing let's double
check yep it has nothing in there so
let's get rid of that duplicate and then
let's get rid of that carousel but we're
not going to use and we can apply our
bulk actions move to trash apply great
all right not bad so once we get
everything set up all we had to do is
run run the commands make a few edits
and we've already got all these in the
system here so you can see how you know
after really probably just a few days
work at most we could have you know all
of the content really after another hour
- we could probably have all the
professors and I'm saying hour or two
because you know assuming something
messes up but this is going to be much
much faster than the alternative which
was having student workers go through
and copy and paste content from the
website to WordPress that would have
taken a really really long time
all right cool soup up five minutes let
me go I'll tell you what let me go to
the live chat I basically because we
went through this process twice already
everything beyond this at least for this
post type is just going to be the same
thing over and over again so there's no
need for me to keep doing the same thing
right you can always you know rewind a
YouTube video and watch it again
so I don't think there's that much value
in doing the same thing again on the
live stream so I'm gonna go to the live
chat now I'm gonna take any any
questions that you have and read out
some of the comments and and then
that'll be it for today's stream
tomorrow I'll try to work on something
else so we'll see let me know right now
in the live chat and in the comments if
you're watching later if you want to see
more of this type of thing of making
custom post types and taxonomies
bringing over data or if you'd like to
move on and get back to some of the
react stuff where we're going to build
out some of these pages now that we have
some of this data on the professors we
can make pages for each department with
content and we can also make pages for
faculty members so at least we can make
that that template page set up the
routing for it so we have some data now
we can play with so we can move back to
the react stuff if we want but I'd like
to know what you all want to see because
I have to do it anyway it's just a
matter of whether I do it on a stream or
not so let me know if I don't hear from
anybody I probably am just going to go
back to the react stuff I could probably
find someone who can run this you know
I'll just say hey watch the video and
keep running this script and fill that
in so I may not even have to do this by
hand but I do need to do the react stuff
there's not really anyone else that I
would be able to just say hey do this
because it's not really a repetitive
task it's more of there's gonna be some
creativity involved alright so let me
check in the chat you scroll up a bit
okay so let's see yes
someone from as Azerbaijan welcome also
and and they liked as well thank you for
the like so streetfighter says I'm not
sure how likes work but it's better to
have them and then not to have them it's
free content that is extremely useful
liking is the least we can do I
appreciate that thank you for saying
that so I mean I I did say earlier I'm
not sure what the likes are for in terms
of you know YouTube and what they use it
for but it is nice when I get a lot of
likes that does make me feel like I'm
doing something worthwhile so
I do appreciate it
let's see code CVS what are you building
here we were building well there's a lot
to this project but in this particular
stream we were building a wordpress
plugin to set up some custom post type
and a custom taxonomy and then we were
pulling data from a another database a
sequel server database and we were
pulling it into our WordPress database
which is my sequel and so that's where
we work on today the bigger picture is
that this data is then going to be fed
into react app and eventually there'll
be a lot more pieces to it so I do
explain some of it in an earlier stream
if you want kind of a more in-depth
explanation so I think maybe like the
the beginning like the first video I did
it for project 5 has a better
explanation yeah and again sorry about
met me messing up the the stream when I
switch networks just didn't we wasn't
thinking and I am sorry because the
viewercount dropped dramatically so I I
think I've lost about at least half of
the people that were watching so sorry
about that
some of you may be rejoined after that
so really really sorry if anybody that
got cut off earlier is watching the
recording later on apologize for that
oh okay john-boy said the URL said the
tag ID let me check that out
oh cool it does say in the URL so the
tag ID is for alright so I don't have to
call the REST API to figure out the tag
ID that's useful I still receive it put
it somewhere in here but I since I could
see in the URL then that's that's fine
too thanks John for for pointing that
out that's very useful
yeah hard yeah your migration
scripts are awesome that was really good
I think I mentioned before like I made
like just really really minor
adjustments like obviously like just
changing a few things like adding in you
know custom post type capabilities here
I think I I get something like right
around here I don't even remember what
it was for sure right now but other than
that like this is perfect yeah really
good I really appreciate that
hey John Anson's here says hey y'all
late sorry
the you weren't here earlier are just
just finishing things up oh cool Harshit
says he's going to make a PR which is a
pull request with the graph QL setup
awesome that that would be really cool
yet I'm interested to see that so I
assume all have to use the WP graph QL
plugin with that which is not a problem
eyes I figured we we did install it at
some point anyway
okay so rook votes for react for the
next stream cool John Hansen vez react
alright code CVS is that database open
to the public
unfortunately it's not so I only have
limited access to this database so I
only have read access to a copy of the
real database and I only have access to
it when I'm on campus at this computer
on one specific network that I can
access from this computer so it's it's
very limited I wonder
all right my for my database people here
is there a way that I could easily make
a copy of this database and then have it
more widely available assuming that I'm
not gonna open up info that shouldn't be
opened up which I'd have to check to see
maybe like potentially remove some
tables or something like that but maybe
that would be better I mean it'd be nice
if like let's say I had to work from
home one day I could still access this
and work on it yeah anyway so I mean
we're not going to do it right now we
don't you do right now but if anybody is
watching now or later on you watch the
recording and you could think of a quick
way to duplicate this database I mean it
might make things easier yeah I mean I
guess I could put it on I don't know
where I'd put it I'd have to check into
like where where I could host a sequel
server database especially a large
sequel server database it might be a
little bit more complicated than I
thought but I think it's worth looking
into just you know so it's accessible to
more people
oh nice okay Harsha says may be hosted
in an azure so that's what I was
thinking of I do have an account with
with Azure already so yeah maybe I'll
look into that and it looks like car
should also found something on Stack
Overflow that I'm checking out right now
yeah let's check this out
interesting all right so there wasn't
back up
so could I make a backup and then just
you step back up somewhere else
okay cool all right maybe I'll look into
that I said there's not absolutely a
need for that right now it would just be
nice to have the option of being able to
access this somewhere else all right
cool
all right that's cool I'm gonna leave
this up on my screen so I I have it I
can remember where I got to this I mean
it's not that hard but rather not have
to think about it again now I did it all
right cool
okay so I've got to the bottom of live
chat here I if I missed your question
I'm sorry you can throw it in the live
chat right now really quickly if I see
it before I am the stream then I'll I'll
answer it otherwise I'm gonna wrap
things up here so thank you so much for
watching thanks for all your help
definitely accomplished what we wanted
to accomplish today and it works things
work like like we thought they would so
I should be back tomorrow and I think
would tomorrow yeah tomorrow's good I
should be back Thursday I don't think
I'm going to be able to stream on
Thursday
so there's um I have a meeting in the
morning and then in the afternoon we
have a Christmas party for my department
so not sure if all if I'll have time to
stream if I can get a short stream and
maybe I'll try but I guess plan on me
not streaming that day I think Friday is
good too to to stream okay we did get
another question I got two more comments
so let me let me read these out so whoa
whoa Jen drah let me know if I
mispronounced that name I'd like to
say it correctly if I can but but gender
assess hi I just knew about it from one
of my friends with topics are included
in here and what time can we on on this
live stream thanks so the live stream is
usually around 2 p.m. Eastern Time
Monday through Friday sometimes I'll go
a little earlier a little later but
that's you know generally around the
time if you subscribe to this channel
the free code camp channel you'll get a
notification assuming you have your
notifications on but you'll get a
notification of when I go live I also
tell everyone on Twitter before I'm
gonna stream so my Twitter link to my
Twitter is in the description of this
video so if you'd like to follow me on
Twitter you'll get an update there as
well
and the topics are mostly JavaScript
stuff like front-end development we do a
lot with react we do some backend stuff
and obviously some database stuff as
well a little bit of PHP because we use
WordPress for some things we use
material design a lot I think that
covers most of what we do so I'm always
open to trying new things if there's
something you'd really like to see me do
I can't guarantee that I'll do it
because these are I work on projects
that I have to work on for my job so I
don't have complete freedom as to what
we do but I'm if I can work in something
new you know I definitely try to anyway
thanks for watching
code CVE says you should put more detail
about what you're working on in the
description yeah and there's a lot more
I'd like to do with the descriptions and
the titles that basically the the
problem I have with the descriptions are
that I write them before I put the
stream on I don't always know what's
gonna happen during the stream so
sometimes the titles and the
descriptions are are completely
different from what we end up doing
because whatever I plan to do just
doesn't work and we have to switch
things up and often I don't go back
usually
and edit a description unless I see you
know like a typo or something so I I
definitely agree with you it's just it's
like it's a time issue for me really to
go back in and do I know it doesn't seem
like a lot but you know at this point I
have over a hundred videos so going back
through and trying to make better
descriptions is going to be pretty
difficult and I can't really make great
descriptions beforehand as I said
because it frequently changes so I don't
ride to go back in afterwards I'll think
about it and I'll try to do better with
the descriptions though so I think
that's good
it's a good idea and I'll see what I can
do I can't promise anything but I'll see
what I can do oh okay harsh it's asking
if I checked out the project I have I've
been looking at the project so i am i
will give you some feedback i guess
Harshit let me know you don't have to
let me know in the live chat now you can
send me something later let me know if
there's anything specifically that you
would like feedback on or just like
feedback in general as to you know what
I see I want to be as helpful as I can
to you so if there's if there's some
area you really would like feedback on
let me know then I can direct you know
my attention to that particular area
otherwise if you want general feedback
that's that's okay too I just want to
help you out as much as I can okay so
I'm that I'm done with the chat now I am
through everything for real this time so
again thanks everyone for watching and
for helping me out here in the live chat
I will be back most likely tomorrow and
in until then have a great day